قبل 22 عاما بدات المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بتصنيع صواريخها صور شحيحه وتفاصيل كثيره
لهذه النقله النوعيه قبل الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من القطاع قصفت المقاومه مناطق
خارج الحدود ولدت التجربه بصاروخ قسام
واحد ضرب استيروت اقرب مستوطنه على قطاع
غزه بعد ذلك باشهر قليله انطلق الصاروخان
جنين وقسام اثنين
لتتسع دائره النار في محيط غلاف غزه ثلاثه
عوامل بعد ذلك دخلت عسقلان شماليه القطاع
الى دائره النار مع دخول صاروخ قسام ثلاثه
الى الخدمه في حرب عام 2008 ادخلت سرايا
القدس صاروخ قدس تجاوز مداه حينها حاجز
الاربعين كيلومترا في الحرب التي تلتها
ادخلت المقاومه صواريخ جديده للخدمه براق
70 وام 75 تو دائره النار الفلسطينيه لتضم
منطقه تل ابيب للمره الاولى عام 2014 دخلت
صواريخ جديده للخدمه انتقلت القدرات نقله
نوعيه بدر ثلاثه وار 160 لتصبح حيفا جزءا
من المدى المستهدف للمره الاولى تنوعت
مدايات الصواريخ صعودا ونزولا لتغطي كل
المناطق داخل الخط الاخضر تقريبا اخر ما
كشف عنه كان في معركه سيف القدس عام 2021
اذ اطلقت كتائب القسام صاروخ عياش 250
ضربت حينها مطار رامون على الحدود مع
الاردن اقصى جنوبي البلاد منذ ذلك الحين
لا يعرف على وجه الدقه عدد الصواريخ التي
تمتلكها المقاومه الفلسطينيه بينما تشير
تقديرات اسرائيليه الى ان كتائب القسام
والسرايا القدس تمتلكان نحو 14
الف صاروخ لم يكن تطوير هذه الصواريخ
عمليه سهله قتلت اسرائيل كل من وصلت اليه
ممن عملوا على هذه النقله النوعيه في
الصراع في قطاع محاصر منذ سبعه عشره سنه